welcome to this video playing chord
Ellis from the US isn't this a character
from the science fiction movie The Fifth
Element at least it sir that's the
translation it's dust front of the
element and German ok we have a play by
bruce willis i'm not mistaken ok so we
got a queen's gambit accepted in this
some in this 15-minute game and the only
line that i really know here I'm afraid
is to capture but that's really a bit
lame for form for the game um what else
yeah there are those Bishop b3 Bishop d3
moves now let's let's play one of those
I don't really know it but I don't
really want to have this end game for 30
minutes on video and some play it in a
bit more aggressive fashion the idea of
this voluntarily voluntarily yeah
voluntarily retreat is some to have a
form available if black plays be five so
rather than reacting to be five with the
bishop move i'm moving at way to have a
four already I think if i'm not mistaken
black has many year possible you see I
can take on d4 Knight B to D 796 and I
don't think b5 is completely terrible
but it's a I guess what white wants 927
yeah
yeah of the night sir often well placed
on 1d seven so what do we get you're
probably an isolated queen porn position
do I play Knight c3 here or maybe this
is running into b5 really thank you okay
don't want to spend ages en the opening
trying to be a bit quicker
yeah many possibilities again be 6b five
Bishop move and also black and just take
on d4 and maybe go for Knight b6 to d5
at some bit of an old-fashioned approach
against the isolated Queens pawn but
it's not it's not terribly bad I mean
wrong wrong phrase at a bit it's okay
for black so just not not a very modern
approach it's a bit more usual nowadays
to attack the pawn like with knight c6
putting pressure on it it's a bit more
more modern than just blocking it yeah
but black takes his sweet time yeah yeah
maybe b5 as an option actually this is
why I hesitated a bit with 93 because b
5 a-4 he's got be four and the text the
night which wasn't the case before I
played it and in a position where the
night is not on c3 a sequence of moves
like be 5 a-4 be for invites Knight d2
to see form so this will be consistency
foursquare and here be 5 a-4 before i
move the light again on c3 and I'm
nowhere near the sea floor square so
maybe b5 is a good good move yeah here
we go I thought that it could be an idea
to to just bring the night over to the
king site like be four 94 be 494 Bishop
d7 ig3 Chan
now it's not a spectacularly great
position yeah maybe 93 wasn't wasn't
really so much to the point
another thing that I'm wondering if I go
BP 494 Bishop e7 if I maybe should just
take on f6 not sure that the night on
g3s is really helping me I take on f6
Knight f6 and then Queenie to John all
that seems to be quite okay for black
anyway yeah Knight c3 was probably a bad
idea at least they're not an idea that
puts black under any kind of pressure
you can just play Bishop birdie 6
castles normal moves young yeah I think
black is so quite good shape yeah I
would actually prefer to play black here
yeah this wasn't so great arm now cam
let's see probably he will just Castle
him what I'd like to do is to play 45
but on e4 he just takes a dd5 then he
takes a three and this sum is just
blundering material ok I will go here to
at least and have a6 attacked
so that he cannot easily play a move
like Roxy aid what I'm what I'm
wondering can he play Bishop d7 and just
grab the ball oops maybe he can maybe he
can but it does not seem to have crossed
his mind look the one firm to have dc5
available if you should play Bishop c7
ok
now it's not easy to play well okay
cannot go in five that's something I
wonder should I get the night to see
form maybe it's not easy be 3s almost
certainly not great because of this
weakness on c3 the other moons I could
play is Bishop we do maybe he's
preparing to play e5 was g6 and g six
and then e five maybe don't don't really
I don't really know I don't see how a
bit beeps b3 is not great I think
because of this weakness so to get the
rooks connected I probably must play
Bishop d2 you should be one something of
that yeah maybe you can do that g6 and
d5 it's maybe an idea
at least he's spending some time on this
so I'm not behind on the clock here
a black has some of course some some
other ideas you can yeah you can also
just take on d5 and it's not clear if it
helps them much but you can do it I will
probably take with the pawn I want to
have this control over a five and c5 I
know it's an isolated pawn but it's a 94
it's just so toothless I don't don't
want to play that yeah maybe okay he's
so regrouping so I'm probably not going
45 I thought he might play 45 yeah still
I cannot go if I deform efore takes d5
Bishop l33t Sharia shame would be nice
okay um what what am I playing maybe
well work on the one that's not doing
much i can i can probably better go here
in case the see file is opening up
yeah that's not easy to play maybe like
g5 to you for this is an idea maybe Jim
the night the night on g3 is also notice
not not especially great lie to see for
would be nice but I don't really I don't
know if I want to play a bit should be
one there should be one looks a really
lame
yeah there should be one he can also
just take on deform purchase okay then i
have rocks yet i don't i don't know i
mean i don't like the move but what
exactly am i doing here I was thinking
also about 95-94 but it's it's basically
not helping mind very tricky position or
let's say let's say I mean I don't
really know what to do to to make any
any headway 92 c 492 to be three this
might be might be something
he takes on d4 I'm taking c8 first at
least I'm a bit ahead on the clock
that's a that might prove useful
okay so he's finally finally clarifying
the situation in the center yeah okay
I'm going to take him Knight takes is
just not helping at all 95 and other
moves here he had me at least and needs
to worry again about the a6 born okay so
this way is covering it let's um let's
see night maybe 95 here brother with 94
coming yeah i don't know i was thinking
what happens if you just place let's say
we should be 70 bishop f8 how do i
actually protect the form
let's let's get this back into plain
maybe allowing Bishop e3 into covered
this is not the type of isolated queen
point position where you play for a
direct attack anyway it's more like a
positional issue on the queenside okay I
think I should go here right and now
ignite c4 or just centralizing it so bad
yeah maybe I can drum up some some sort
of a tech here with night age five and
and this type of moves aha okay I would
okay and I cd4 is also hanging so I
cannot take on a six well that's bad
oh man this is not not nice at all 96
with a strong move yeah I cannot even
retreat
maybe not g4m come on I need any two to
get going in Knight f3 could just take a
five I think I need to maybe you can
really try for the tech here but Sir
it's it's too it's too shaky everything
I don't know if that was great i have i
have cool ok i can not can I not know
that really it asks for sacrifice really
here
but it's probably not sound
okay where else can I go I can go here
to H form the thing is he will take d
for this is really an important pond
here there should be seven let's not
yeah but I don't really I don't really
think I can sacrifice my Cuba ship takes
he takes Knight a5 that's not that's not
really threatening much
don't really know where to go even
though that's that's really a really a
pain to eat too very very ugly d 4 eggs
with temple
yeah that's not great at all but I don't
really know what else this should be
seven simply
now you can take you for night h5 was my
my intention it does not have this year
but ok maybe we can play age 60
Wow
yup like it's just very close to to have
a winning position maybe this is a win
already it's a pawn very nicely night on
position right on default I don't I
don't see anything great here now
understandable he wants to exchange
Queen's gym how am I going to avoid it
Queen f4 that's not really great you
don't know what else to do night v3i
kabuki one at least make this is just
great for black
25 how am I going to defend it 25 s I'm
probably not bad f3 I think you can even
take a 325 f 393 GF 23 is easy queena
three Queen default check it's also
terrible check okay is trying to play
her even more no more direct fashion
yeah special person strong piece o no
doubt about that
yeah maybe even rooks if I've got to
check okay Brooksie for its not winning
hmm gather him not quite sure what this
is doing really attacking here okay look
do you want this is not not a great one
just takes it what is ISM we just do if
you just wants to take the pawn or maybe
maybe
I want to take on only six if he grabs
okay I need to initiate counterplay here
print checks yeah maybe I should Aaron
should cover it briefly just like rookie
to my counter play could be against g7
okay yeah probably i should do that if
it takes on b2 we s kappa g 7 covered ok
twin g5f for therefore i can play night
age five
you can cover with regev 7 all night h5
of course yeah what can you do check
again if i go here he even has a look g6
on top of all of it
time warning yeah h5 that's just that's
just f for now maybe 94 94 at least to
continue
yeah it so just just lost here F 494
look somewhere i don't i don't really
have have much okay can go back to you
one or something and and hope i have
could clean g6 check okay sorry i got
Corinne g6 check that's maybe something
maybe I can somehow he does not need to
play that he can play any sort of move
takes only three years a draw with
Knight f6 I came yeah I doubt that that
was the best way to play maybe it's done
good enough got this check here
but it's justice check right can i
somehow i guess i can't check
alright you can just take it check it
does not take them check check
let's check it's a lucky escape bring
him check check check check drawn out
drama Wow yeah this was a this was
completely completely lost not that I
can can tell easily at which point but
it was certainly certainly just around
here he can he can probably play many
non forcing moves gentle wind relatively
easily I needed to do that and now just
just not f4 I mean maybe our four winds
as well no it doesn't it's really a draw
okay it's very tempting of course yeah
the computer just wants to play a move
like this and then I'm certainly a lot
of ideas I don't I cannot play anything
yet just just just completely paralyzed
I can just stick and just take take here
would be to enter it's a wife no no move
and this seems to be a draw it's at it
appears to be a draw funny check
I actually thought that he could try
this but ok is giving up a six in the
process this is not not clear at all
yeah yeah that I they just around here
and it went totally totally wrong night
b8 was strong really ok and now here
around here this is this is probably
probably a mistake I don't know now at
least this is a mistake yeah g4s hanging
the alternative was to take and then
play something like that which looks
really ugly but maybe I should do that
it's it's not like I'm losing
immediately it just looks very
unattractive black is in good shape
anyway yeah this wasn't a very
successful operation and this is just
good for black yeah computer actually
wants to play night at five maybe this
is better relatively speaking this is
really terrible there is also this
exceptionally good bishop so I'm just
I'm just struggling here and here I
thought he would still um improve the
position somewhat but this is just wrong
I mean it just it's just just completely
winning for black I'm just trying to
muddy the waters but term get laid it
excellently I mean he's just keeping the
winning hand just only f4 only f4 is
giving it away with the probably this
there's a multitude of good move so
there's not only this Quincy to that I
pointed
out what the engine pointed out yeah he
really should have won that but you
still need to to to be precise until
there was last IDF 494 alright thanks
for watching